what's up it's your girl Tink and I want
to make sure you know my album is coming
out thanks for nothing February 24th
make sure you go get it I'm tuned in
with bootleg Kev podcast let's get it
you ready I'm ready okay
stabou Lake Cab podcast bootleg cash
show special guest Tink thank you
they're very talented thank you thank
you so much historically uh leveled
talented person like the levels of
talent you possess is historic thank you
no I really appreciate that yeah I think
it's been dope to just kind of witness
like the last few years the Run you've
been going on doing it independently yes
sir
um
I've been a fanny for a very long time
so it's good to see you no thank you I
mean a lot like you said two years I've
been independent
it's a different vibe different energy
yeah like how do you uh because you kind
of been through the ringer if you will
you've had like a long journey
throughout the music industry right
you've been on the major label side
you've been working with guys like
Timberland guys like this guy over here
who has bad cigarette smoking problem
AKA hit me
um but like for you like how how does it
feel to kind of like have a little bit
more freedom now and it feels like
you're doing a lot of stuff on your
terms now yeah that's is what makes it
fun to be honest it feels like
I'm just being myself now yeah when I
was first like in the industry or in the
game it was a lot of labelheads over my
situation
so you know I'm just getting back to
myself and really you know being
authentic again yeah with the music I'm
able to say what I want to say you know
work with who I want to work with yeah
it's just that freedom yeah for you like
I feel like when you first came out too
there was like kind of it was kind of
like a weird time to be like a female
artist who does like hip-hop slash r b
you're kind of like a hybrid artist
right and now I just feel like it's all
lining up for you how do you feel about
just kind of the landscape of Music in
2023 as opposed to when you first came
in obviously the industry's changed a
lot you know yeah it has
um
I feel like it's uh it's more accepted
like you said back then it was kind of
I was like the
I don't want to say the only one doing
it but it was rare to hear like a rapper
you might have been the only one doing
it right I hate to say it like that but
maybe she was a female like Lauren Hill
yeah so like in my generation I was the
only one doing it so it was you know it
was a um it took me a minute to really
you know just put put it out there um
but now it's honestly I feel like the
game is just more accepting yeah you
know we got like artists that are doing
like rock and rap you know I feel like
the the music the genres I blend in
together more and it's I think it's
resulting in better music too exactly
and people are free
um yeah so yeah I think uh
you know I've always just done me I've
never really put a box put myself in a
box right
but yeah it's working it's working out
for sure you've had some dope records
too uh thank you I'm glad you brought up
the wrap I think people forget that I
can really rap you could rap rap yeah I
can really rap I mean you've been on
your r b tip like some real ill r b [__]
but sure you can rap that's I mean
that's what got me as a fan was like oh
this coconut she could bar out but she
also thank you but what's so crazy rap
is like so hard to really for me it's
really hard to like kick down the door
and rap right like the female the female
rappers you know it's just a different
ball game I feel like r b
people are more like receptive to my r b
songs when you first came out what year
was it like on a major label 2015. so
2015 the landscape of being a female
rapper quote unquote is way different
way different it was really loud Nikki
yeah and then Queen Nick and yeah shout
out to Nikki yeah and then there was uh
well 2015. it wasn't a lot of female
rappers deje days love she was like
2014. you know but yeah it was
definitely tough because it and it kind
of there was like this female
Renaissance if you will around 2017 2018
where it was like and I I look at music
currently specifically hip-hop there's
like a lack of real records in rap right
now like if you really think about
like what has been the smash this year
that you go to the club and it's like
automatic like there's [__] to play for
sure there's [__] to play but
the days I just there's not like like
these dudes ain't making anthems no more
like uh now glorilla is making a [__]
Anthem you know what I'm saying like I
love me some glorella like Megan's
making real records you know what I mean
um [__] coil array the player's record
is a dope that's a hit it's a hit you
know what I mean I just feel like dudes
are just like kind of like women are
taking over to be honest I have I hear
more of the girls rapping than I do with
the guys and they're making just better
songs absolutely and we we know our
audience too like you know women are
speaking for women so yeah you know do
you feel like uh you should have got
nominated for a Grammy
uh
I don't want to say that now I think you
know I'm really hot on myself I'm a hard
critic so I got a lot of work to put in
still right
um and like I say I'm really just
getting my foot in that door again yeah
so um with time and I don't really make
music to like be nominated nowhere I
feel like you know if it happens it
happens if it happens it happens and I'm
grateful
but um you know that's not like the end
of for sure like so many artists that
never really got there yeah got their
Grammy or got their Awards but uh I mean
Nas barely just won a Grammy last year
and it was like 20 25 years later after
him yeah
it's crazy yeah no so yeah uh this new
album is well first of all explain the
title
so my new album is called thanks for
nothing
um and it's going to be released in
February
and I really wanted to make a project
that was like geared towards the women
of course but Valentine's Day is coming
up and you know me I'm always speaking
for my ladies yep I'm always talking
about heartbreaks and
relationship issues and that's like my
core so I was like it's perfect time
thanks for nothing it's an album is that
what you tell like an ex that's what I
tell my ex so you get you go through a
breakup it's like thanks for nothing
thanks for wasting my [__] thanks for
wasting my time that's it you know
thanks for nothing is that the hardest
part about going through a bad breakup
where it's like I just wasted like some
Prime real estate in my life with this
[__] guy of course that's the that's
the worst part about it you can't get
time back but you can get lessons from
it true yeah that's the upside you know
you always learn yeah learn from
everything but
I like how you said that though it's
like man
took my time and wasted it
that's true because if you're in your
like 20s early 30s like you're like yo
like this is the prime of my life yeah
don't take that lightly don't waste my
[__] time exactly
um and I'm 27 so like
it is like that Prime you know that age
where you know
yeah
but you know we don't have no more time
to waste so you and uh Mr Berg AKA hit
maker how many times Platinum 100
millions of I mean what are we at Berg
over there excuse me
120 and so non-chunk crazy this guy's
crazy super talented got an ear for hit
records how uh you guys have been
working together for a while now but in
terms of your guys's cohesion it's
almost like the r b version of like DJ
Premiere and Guru from gang star where
like you guys are like very much like in
sync with each other and putting these
records together explain like your
guys's relationship and the chemistry
there
you know what's really dope about us
working together we both from Chicago
yes you are yep so when I when I met
hitmaker it was very comfortable
you know like I'm an artist where I like
to kind of go in the studio alone and
you know I like to just kind of be free
and have the room to myself right when
he came in
it was easy to work with him I didn't
feel like bombarded it wasn't like you
know singing like this do this
a lot of producers are pushy right and
it's not like that Wham and he
understands me too like we from the shot
so he get my my lingo you know he
understand my language
so it just made it really easy
yeah I feel like you guys are in your
guys like because he is he he did the
whole album yeah the whole album
executive produced the whole album wow
so so that's major you know what I mean
like like you say 120 million it's a lot
a billion close to a billionaire
13 billion streams yeah that's major
yeah that's a lot you know yeah super
slept on guy over there sitting on the
on the rug over there we need more
chairs by the way sorry guys it's the
first day in the new place we need more
chairs it's obvious yeah congrats it's
really nice yeah the front building is
where it's at but nah we're here uh for
you is there any features on this album
so I have one feature very very very
special feature
um
should I give away the surprise guys
so Ty dollar sign is on this album sign
yes listen that's like legendary for me
I really really
you know just always have been a great
fan of Ty dollars that tie he's just so
good he's just like he's like a cheat
code for sure so cheat cheat code um but
on our record we're going back and forth
so it's a real it's a real record did
you ever think that Ty and Berg look
like they could be kin to each other in
some capacity like if you grew out
dreadlocks like it's the eyes he might
be able to have a second career as a Ty
Dollar Sign stand-in you know what I
mean
you've heard that before Berg
or am I being am I being like 10 racist
right now
[Laughter]
yo for sure the iced tea thing okay yeah
Iced Teas no iced tea son no
he is iced Tea's son
that's Iceberg right there for sure
there it is what's up guys hey shout out
to our family at uh Bluetooth man listen
I know we always are getting feedback
about our Bluetooth interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's they're
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discrete package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollar shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be every
erection should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being uh
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up well go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to send you a
month for free they also just dropped
the mint chewable same active ingredient
as Levitra that's right so what you need
to do
I mean you don't need to do anything if
you want to you know not be as hard as
you can be that's on you but
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you
I'm in Arizona right now this is just
random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks and we got
the odd Sox Basics baby yeah so look so
this was stuff about odd stocks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff oddsoxofficial.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you will save 20 off at checkout try the
Odd Socks Basics if you're one of those
guys who wears other plain white branded
socks plain black socks I promise you go
with the odd Sox basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable they're way more durable
and they just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro Stand Down be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview uh for
you
give me your RnB Mount Rushmore
oh Beyonce okay maybe
Mary J Blige okay
Laura Hill
um
let me some scissors scissor
yes all females on the Mount Rushmore
yeah yeah for sure not the other guy
from Chicago who's a legend but you know
not the best person who's that
Robert Kelly you say his name no
no but I gotta rap for the ladies I feel
like that's who I really lean on when uh
incredible you love SOS that's a great
album yes yes she did her [__] you know
and scissors like a Pioneer she's like
in her own
laying her own world
um yeah I love scissors oh yeah she
inspired me a lot you know what it is
too is like you know you're an amazing
female R B artist when you can get like
a dude to like appreciate and this is
true like because you're you're the same
type of artist where you can like
because there's a lot of female r b for
me that like well this is not I can't
relate to this it's like you know I'm
not a scorned woman so yeah yeah but
then when I be hearing your [__] or I'd
be hearing scissors [__] I'm just in
like yeah and that's that's the beauty
of it but what's so crazy I feel like a
lot of guys are
they get like upset behind my music
because I kind of keep it too real and
too honest so I'm glad to have your
support as a guy yeah a lot of guys I
see it all the time like man you know my
lady is mad at me because of you or you
got me in trouble you know okay give me
like a song lyric that might have got a
guy in trouble that day I got a record
don't tell nobody with Jeremiah says
like dropped it a long time ago but to
this day it goes crazy
um what are you saying I'm like like
where's your way the guy's cheating
keeping on the DL [__] you say you with
the Bros and you out with a [__] oh
yeah so you're at the crib man you
leaving her place pull up to the crib
[__] lie on my face wow
such as real [__] like that I love to
come raw and like same way the guys rap
and like they drop bombs and [__] that's
how I'm coming for the women I love it
so yeah I'm glad to have some support
from the males
oh [__] how can I overlook so the last
record we just wrapped it that's why
there's another feature with young blue
and it's called stingy
um amazing record you know working with
blue is so you know so easy he's got a
super dope tone too yeah I love his
voice yes very unique come on SO stingy
is dropping really soon it's gonna be on
radio as well produced by airmaker
and that's the vibe you know were you
guys in the studio together for that one
no we weren't we actually uh sent it to
me and uh we kind of just went back and
forth with it until it was right for you
like what is your like writing process
because obviously being able to rap
being able to like
do the lyrical [__] yeah yeah but also
being able to like write songs like are
you open to input like when it comes to
like top lines or hooks or [__] like
that because obviously you're in the
studio with bergberg is obviously
a great songwriter yeah
I'm open now I used to be really really
like you know I kept my music really to
myself right I'd write it at home and go
to the studio cut it by myself you know
nobody would hear my [__] until it kind
of was about to release but now working
with he kind of introduced me to working
with other writers right you know he'll
he'll have the studio open and it'll be
like 10 people in a booth at once so I
think it's good in the industry honestly
everybody's taking
taking you know yeah he's like if you've
been in like an actual studio session
yeah you kind of know what it is it's
like it's like a bunch it's just a
free-flowing flow of ideas yeah and we
get a lot of [__] done quicker like it
could be the engineer given ideas too
you know exactly and that and for some
reason they never get any credit shout
out to the engineers yeah shout out to
Suarez you know
um so it says engineering my last album
so
we've been working really really hard
um
but yay everybody has like a input into
the [__] now so you know we coming
harder what is uh so the Grammys just
got uh wrapped up uh
Harry Styles when I'm in here
but for you what was your favorite album
okay I don't even want to go Grammy
cycle because it's a little confusing to
remember what came out from September to
September but what was your favorite
album last year
my favorite album last year I like
underground like artists not even
underground but like Brent fires Brent
fire is almost crazy toxic as hell I
played that [__] out very toxic album I
love it yes
um so for me that was my top album you
know
and I don't mean to say underground but
I love like you know people that aren't
may not be on the radio 24 7. right so
those are principals he's a beast his
band is crazy too super crazy pin what
about on the hip-hop side
hip-hop side
yeah and it might have been a light year
for for rep I mean yeah there was some
good [__] there was like uh Kendrick
Pusha T okay okay what else was dope
last year
future hey okay
future damn near RMB artist now like
wait for you it's like a brilliant r b
record I fear you
but yeah I'm still locked in with RMV I
guess I didn't really tune into much
much I was on that r b [__] yeah
I've been going through it so okay the
guy who won best r b album that Chris
Brown did not know who he was did you
know who he was I didn't know who he was
at all okay but
you know did you leave yeah some someone
knows though someone knows yeah
but I do feel like Chris deserved
he deserved listen
I think Chris Brown is probably him or
Jamie Foxx in terms of just talent in
one body yeah
the most talented [__] in the
world
because like Chris Brown Can Dance you
can sing you can paint an Entertainer he
could [__] uh he could play
basketball I just mean Talent I'm not
even tomorrow just everything yeah and
then you got Jamie Foxx who could do
stand up he can act he can that's crazy
he is a comedian as well those two are
like the two unicorns if we're just
talking about raw talent
Chris Brown's like I feel like I feel
like sometimes we don't appreciate Chris
enough absolutely I do feel like he's
he's like the closest
we have to Mike he's our mic he's our
mic for sure
so yeah to see somebody else win like
that it did break break our hearts you
know I felt I felt Chris on that and
Chris Brown is almost hard it was I mean
look not I don't even like the other guy
I didn't listen to his album so I I
could be better and that's the thing I
hadn't heard heard of it um I didn't
listen to Harry Styles that's why the
Grammys you know we got to be careful
giving you know give any award shows too
much
well you know what they did this year
they realized nobody was watching so
they just made that [__] hip hop as [__]
right I heard they had a hip-hop tribute
it was not just that it was like the
whole show ended with like Jay-Z rapping
out of the last supper with DJ Khaled
little baby did freestyle at the Grammys
this is amazing it was amazing well I'm
glad to hear that though we do need more
you know just more involvement I don't
want to [__] up his name I think it's
Jesse Collins the guy who produced the
Grammys but he's the guy who always does
the beat who's been doing the BET Awards
the last few years so they had to kind
of tap in because and then and people
were talking about the Grammys in a
positive way this year yeah but that's
the thing you know rap really influences
everything so you know if you want
people to tune in you gotta you gotta
balance it out yeah for sure have you
been able to link with uh like someone
like scissor who you're a fan of or like
any of the other any of your you know
because there's a lot of people who are
doing their thing that have come out
kind of after you like they're like Doja
cat or you know
um Samia says that we haven't met but
she always shows love on like socials
and yeah she's always supporting you
know when I drop
so it's love there I can't wait to run
into her yeah you know so I can like you
know since we gotta go to the studio got
to got to that'd be legendary yeah
that's like a dream collab scissor you
know she's Pioneer what's up y'all
bootleg Kev here hey look my bookie man
it's a big weekend in sports the big
game is Sunday Chiefs versus Eagles I'm
all in on the Eagles
I like Jalen hurts over on the passing
yards over on the rushing yards anytime
touchdown score give me Dallas Goddard
anytime touchdown score give me the over
and if anyone on the Chiefs is going to
score I like that Pacheco kid I like the
little running back guy and of course
you gotta Hammer Travis Kelsey anytime
touchdown score you can do all that at
my bookie right now all right so many
props to bet on at my bookie this
weekend you can bet on the Gatorade
color that gets poured out you could bet
on the on the flip the the coin flip at
the beginning of the game all that right
now at my bookie sign up with the promo
code bootleg when you sign up
they will match your very first deposit
up to one thousand dollars with that
promo code bootleg so go to mybookie.ag
sign up for an account
promo code bootleg whatever you put in
they're gonna double it
as long as it's not more than a thousand
you put 999 dollars in they're gonna
give you another 9.99
you put a thousand in and leave you
another thousand by the way if you do
the 9.99 why not just do the full
thousand you cheap bastard anyway my
bookie right now man it's a big weekend
also I just would like to point out
everyone should be putting some of that
money sprinkling a little bit of that
action on the Phoenix Suns win the
championship this year because we have
Kevin Durant oh yeah oh yeah my bookie
sign up with that promo code bootleg
also shout out to our family at hardean
hardine Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
a customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot
them a follow on Instagram while you're
at it go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com so much fly gear so
much fly weed what are we talking about
baby shout out to hardine man that's the
family man go if you're in Vegas pull up
on them man Jardine Las Vegas yeah how
do you feel about uh because obviously
Chicago has is probably
man Chicago if we just think about like
the history of hip-hop that's come out
of Chicago it's very diverse it's vast I
mean in my opinion yeah you know Kanye's
probably the got the best discography
ever and then you got like the new [__]
which is like you know obviously
shout out to Dirk and those guys Polo G
everybody but like uh is there anybody
in Chicago that you're you're checking
for that maybe we haven't heard of yet
ah
that's a great question you know we have
a few singers that are really doing that
thing
um John Doe is dope
um there's a singer Sansa Ann Marie
um
but you know what we really had our our
big run in like 2012 when Keith and yeah
we're going crazy it was it was just
different for all of us
um
but yeah Chicago we've got very talented
I think we get a lot of flat because
like the violence and [__] or like you
know just because our nature
yeah I mean listen a lot I mean you know
that is that there is something to be
said that yeah it goes straight to you
know the shootings and killings yeah
um sometimes I think that over overrides
like you know The Talented [__] we got
going also just the city in general
because like I know it's not like like I
think when a lot of people think of
Chicago they think it's like
bad everywhere and it's like a great
City it's a great city
um and then on top of that though like
you know people coming out of Chicago we
aren't evil people or you know we got
great you know we do great things in the
city as well how do you deal with like
nine degree weather I'm just curious
like what do you do do you just stay
inside yeah okay we got like you have to
layer up I can't tell you how many coats
and scarves and [__] like that I have
like it's crazy would you like I just
wouldn't leave I'm Eric I'm Uber eating
everything exactly ubereats deliver
everything
no but for me though I think um you know
we're used to it like we grew up in and
we walk to school in the cold like that
so Jesus I guess it's like accustomed to
it now yeah yeah okay we talked about
your Mount Rushmore r b what about if
shy town
oh that's good
we gotta have yay of course Jesus
um
that's deep because we got like all like
classical rappers but then we also got
like the new generation I feel like
there's two spots that should not be
disputed it should be Kanye and Chief
Keef cave has to be because I think
Chief Keef is one of the most
influential artists him both of them but
darchio is also going crazy
it's so hard you know we got different
Vibes like everybody's a goat in their
own right and that's the thing about
Chicago okay but I'm forcing you to fill
out too much I know it's all right Kim
okay we got Kanye
then I will have to put common in like
lyrically one of the greatest MCS to
ever live okay Chief Keef so we got
three yeah and it is one more
can I get a spot on the mountain you
know for the lady give yourself this
[__] yeah I'm gonna go up too hey shout
out to Chicago please amazing female
artist too shout out to Shawna Shawna
come on no that's big sis what's so
crazy
man life is just like crazy from Chicago
had a relationship too oh really yeah I
feel like they grew up next to each
other they were neighbors it's cold yeah
so that's a big sis to me as well so
shout out to Shawna Drizzy is from
Chicago yeah you know another dope
rapper yeah she's hard her how my hip
was fire okay girl that's my point you
know we got a lot of talent for sure
Chicago's winning yo listen do you
remember Crucial Conflict I do
of course or Do Do or Die Do or Die come
on man twist it oh man speeding up
mobsters
twister was a
for a second in my life Twista
and do or die was like
that heads or tails album or the album
or the penny on it oh my God yeah the
[__] Perfect album damn and then
Crucial Conflict was beefing with Bone
Thugs-N-Harmony about who was doing the
sing song of fast rap first yeah good
times man the Midwest rap Beef Cleveland
versus Chicago
I'm old as you can tell I see um well
listen uh the new album
thanks for nothing thanks for nothing
February 24th
um it's amazing you know what I mean
like I'm coming for the ladies that's
all I do so before
give some ladies out there you've you've
been through I'm sure you've been
through heartbreak in your life
right give me your advice to anyone
listening that's going through a bad
breakup yo my advice to anyone listening
if you're going through a bad breakup
I want you to know
that it is not the end of the world life
goes on and life gets better you know
what I mean keep your head up and you're
the prize you know don't forget that
part never forget that part you have a
kid guy's car
I have Kev I had to admit that I hate so
I made it I keep cars I in the past when
I was younger I uh cut a couple tires
tear up some clothes
I haven't torn clothes but I did get out
the car you got at the car did you break
a window no I didn't break the window
but I put them on a flat damn what do
you do like you just get a knife and
just you know yeah it was a knife wow
and this car was in the drive
and then uh kind of cheating
you know what I did catch some cheetah
and I actually caught him through his
iPad
so you know the eye message in there
exactly his eye his messages went to his
iCloud and wow so he didn't even know he
left the iPad back at the crib thinking
he was out here and yes
I went through every message wow
wow yeah just [__] his tires up yeah I
I regret that though I'm really a
changed person well that's good A lot of
people don't know that I I've changed so
much so much growth I interviewed
gorilla and she said that she caught her
man cheating and she snuck a gun in the
club and she was about to murder him in
the club she pulled a gun out on and uh
right yeah so hey I mean listen who
cares about a tire or two right a little
paper yeah yes you just change it keep
it moving listen the album go run it up
and uh I'm assuming it's early in the
year but we might get another one this
year you never know absolutely I'm
working on a few more crazy projects my
fans have been uh you do like just a
mixing waiting on a wedding a winter
project a wrap project
you know what
I think I want to do that for sure and
drop it as a tape yeah that's not even
like political eight song ten song where
you're just going in thanks get some
like that's a fire idea for real yeah
just to like you gotta just remind
people exactly and they wanted to so
yeah you never know watch out there it
is thanks appreciate you pulling up
thank you perfect love
fire
now this was great thank you